[Music]
this is breaking news out of Pakistan to
bring you the former President Pervez
Musharraf has been sentenced to death
this is in connection with a treason
case Kemal hiders on the line now from
Istanbul I'm sorry Aslam about her with
more details Kemal tell us more yes a
big work eggs from the special court
which was constituted back in 2013 were
trying him for high treason for an act
committed in 2007 which was considered a
violation of the Constitution when he
suspended the Constitution and imposed
emergency rules so it gets intense after
so many years of deliberation he of
course was declared an expander back in
2016 but Musharraf health has been
deteriorating he said to be in critical
condition in the hospital and goodbye
he of course challenged that he was not
able to represent himself because of the
health condition
the court has actually reserved the
voltage alia Bhatt made that
announcement today
come on so what does it actually amount
to then if he has eventually essentially
been been tried in absentia and he's ill
as well as this just a a court ruling
which nothing may actually happen on it
a lot of pressure because his actions in
2007 were deemed as unconstitutional and
therefore constituted treason charges
against him so he the fact that he is
overkill he's got support by in other
countries as well and because of his
deteriorating health of course it's
extreme concern he's in poor shape so I
don't think that the court will be able
to use its influence to bring him back
into Pakistan and then to triumph or I
ought to hang him or whatever say no I
don't think it will have any bearing on
that okay just reminders quickly as well
because I remember you doing plenty of
courting on this at the time the
suspension of the Constitution the the
emergency rule why did he do that at the
time well at the time he was faced with
a lot of opposition for suspending the
chief justice if there are moments
Audrey here most of the judges did not
agree with the moves there was a
judicial commission that was formed and
the tide turned against Musharraf before
that he was quite popular but his move
to suspend and to put the judges to
retire that is a sense that was
something that did not go down well so
even though the official doubles by 2011
for those actions or the web acted
against the judiciary okay come on
harder thank you for that updates that's
coming out of Pakistan former President
Pervez Musharraf sentenced to death in
connection with a treason case as Kamala
was saying that goes back to 2007 when
he suspended the Constitution and
imposed emergency law but former
President Musharraf
is in Dubai at the moment and apparently
an ill health and was tried in absentia
here okay